Reading manga expectations:
This is Ben.
He is a careful and methodical guy.
He always keeps his work calendar up-to-date and always responds to emails.
He has a 401-K and is also considered an elite Yelper.
He never starts a manga series he knows he can't finish...
...and always sets up his space for optimal reading.
He makes sure he always has a hot beverage, clean reading glasses.
He always makes sure to set a timer...
...for the precise amount of allotted time to read his manga.
He turns his phone on airplane mode to eliminate any possible disturbances.
He always reads slowly and methodically to ensure 100 percent reading comprehension.
Ben does not exist.